alors cette enquête pour étaler attiser
un peu plus les tensions entre le mali
et la france place à notre décryptage
est avec nous pour en parler claude
blanchemaison expert en relations
internationales à vos côtés abdelkerim
compte du goût me chercheur associé au
groupe à fils de lips bonsoir monsieur
merci d'être avec nous également on
vient d'entendre un donc l' agence
française de développement qui aurait
fourni selon mediapart notamment fourni
des armes des militaires accusés
d'exactions au sahel c'est une enquête
et des faits qui qui vous semblent
crédibles adelkarim kuniomi
le rapport dit vrai et nous avons
constaté c'est là depuis très longtemps
le sla conséquences mais cette vision
centralisée et étatiste de la mda ce qui
concerne l'aide au développement qui ne
correspond parfois pas aux besoins réels
des populations et l'efficacité des
cette aide à son adaptation à une
situation de lutte contre le terrorisme
la conséquence directe de cela c'est la
vision de la lutte contre le terrorisme
qui est uniquement centralisé sur
l'aspect militaire de cette lutte contre
ce fléau
ne droits de l'homme la bonne
gouvernance la démocratie ont été
complètement mis de côté et tout a été
centralisé sur l'âme et la solution de
l'âme et quand on voit
les gouvernements de cette zone des x5
sa reine par exemple le tchad qui est
dirigé par un régime autoritaire où son
pouvoir est basé sur le plier de l'armée
qui est
militarisée et à son service une armée
de répression cette armée de répression
qui ne respectent pas les droits humains
indisciplinés qui n'est pas formé qu'on
utilise cette armée et qu'on a cette
année pour ses soldats on les amène sous
les chants de lutte contre le terrorisme
est évidemment ces armes et se comporte
exactement comme il se comporte dans
leur propre pays
c'est de cela que sept rapports
absolument raison et qu'il fallait
vraiment et urgemment avec le chiffre
sur la façon de les voir cette stratégie
aussi les droits humains et la bonne
gouvernance blanche présence avec cette
agence française de développement elle
est le symbole de la solidarité de la
france dans le monde c'est vrai que pour
le grand public on a du mal à y voir
clair parce que c est fait c'est un sale
coup en conscience pour son image que
quel est votre diagnostic quand vous
entendez monsieur s'exprimer comme ça
est ce qu'il ya des nuances à apporter
il ya sûrement des choses à revoir et à
améliorer sur le mode de fonctionnement
mais l' agence française de
développement ne craint pas grand chose
quant à sa réputation d'abord pour des
raisons historiques et politiques il se
trouve que l'ancêtre de l' agence
française de développement
c'est la caisse de financement de la
résistance fondé par le général de
gaulle en 1941 bien sûr ensuite ça a
beaucoup évolué puisque ensuite elle se
consacrait comme vous l'avez dit à la
coopération avec l'afrique
essentiellement l'afrique francophone et
puis au fur et à mesure des années ses
compétences se sont élargies et se sont
élargies à l'ensemble de l'afrique puis
à l'asie puis à l'amérique latine se
sont élargies aussi à des sujets qui
étaient gérés auparavant directement par
le ministère de la coopération de la rue
monsieur qui n'existe plus en tant que
telle et à un moment où il est apparu
que partout dans les pays développés la
gestion des dossiers de coopération
devait être confié à une agence et ne
devait pas être fait par un ministère le
ministère devait donner les lignes
directrices établir la stratégie mais
c'est une agence qui devait monter les
actions et c'est le cas avec l' agence
française de développement je vois aussi
insisté sur le fait qu' il s'agit
évidemment d'un établissement public à
caractère industriel et commercial aussi
d'institutions financières et qu'elle a
le fameux triple a que donnent les
agences de notation c'est à dire qu'elle
peut emprunter sur les marchés dans les
meilleures conditions et là elle le fait
puisque elle a un rôle multiple elle est
à la fois la banque de nos territoires
d'outre-mer elle est la banque par
lequel transitent les dons de l'état aux
pays qui ne peuvent pas emprunter parce
que ils sont déjà en dehors des
conditions d'emprunt ne pourrait pas
rembourser et puis elle est aussi une
banque de développement c'est-à-dire
qu'elles prêtent avec
des taux qui peuvent être éventuellement
bonifié par le gouvernement français
elle fait tous ces métiers là avec des
techniciens qui apparaissent compétents
la preuve c'est que elle a gardé son
triple a mais ça n'empêche pas en effet
que des réformes soit souhaitable
justement dans la continuité de ce que
vous venez nous dire c'est elle en tire
vient d'investir des milliards d'euros
pour développer l'afrique notamment
beaucoup d'argent en jeu est
nécessairement des lequel il compte de
gomis des parts d'ombré
je ne suis pas parfaitement d'accord les
fagots la ld doit s'occuper de
développement de l'afrique et sur sa
seule vision et sa méthode je crois que
la r d doit aussi écouter les africains
écoutez la société civile africaine et
les désirs des populations et leur façon
d'aller vers cet accompagnement dans
cette population a besoin l'afd ne doit
pas seulement à faire le parallèle avec
les états étant donné qu'on n'a pas des
états fiables dans cette zone si on
avait d état correct d'une bonne
gouvernance et que tout fonctionne
normalement et que c'est une question de
lutte contre la pauvreté oui si
seulement la lutte contre la pauvreté ça
marchera mais c'est assez complète la
situation dans le sahel on apprend en
même temps cinq défis différentes la
lutte contre le terrorisme la lutte pour
la sécurité et la stabilité
la lutte pour la liberté la démocratie
et la lutte contre la pauvreté il ya
tellement de lutte que se profilent à 60
en train de mener
tout est maintenant ce qui s'est passé
que les politiques des états les
politiques des 16 agences de
développement les politiques d'autres
organisations se sont tellement mélanger
et tout devient confus il est en
étudiant d'éclaircir et donner à chacun
sa mission claire ce qui doit aider la
population à aider versé développement
et ceux qui font leurs politiques
publiques et leurs dépendants de leur
intérêt dans cette zone c'est très
important de pouvoir dissocier vous avez
dit tout à l'heure le début que cette
crise où cet article sans homophobes il
ya une tension politique sur entre la
france le gouvernement français le
gouvernement actuel du mali sur des
questions de la vision aux commandes
luttez pas que le tourisme et cela
maintenant en train de s'imposer sur la
l'action de l'afd voyez donc maintenant
la question que ce n'est plus en tout
cas de mon point de vue la r d doit
revoir sa façon de faire de ne plus
travailler avec uniquement les états
d'être très exigeants et pointus dans
les détails c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui
l'arrêté ne peut pas dire en donnant ces
âmes en armant ses militaires à l'effort
mais est-ce que même si l'objectif
aujourd'hui est d'avoir les soldats qui
respecte la lutte pour les droits
humains dans l'émission de stabilité
dans l'élite en terrorisme l'un d'eux
doit être très exigeant pour christian
militaire ne retourne pas cet art
populaire population pour défendre des
régimes indéfendable cela et c'est un
piège ils doivent éviter ces pièces là
et ne peut pas dire utiliser
l'utilisation des ces armes ce n'est pas
nous en a donné les armes les séries qui
les utilisent donc on n'est pas
responsable non ce n'est pas possible si
encore une soit on est de ceux d'état à
avoir des armes et digne le public n
quels espoirs des blues une heure avant
de les amener dans des missions ailleurs
ou bien on ne forme pas on ne donne pas
des armes car quand on sait que ces
militaires sont potentiellement des
indisciplinés et qui ne respectent pas
le droit jeunes a classé la et la
responsabilité de la sb tour blanche
maison c'est vrai que
met le doigt sur effectivement le
problème pour l' agence en gros la
responsabilité prend fin lorsque le
propriétaire d'aidé matérielle et
transférés aux bénéficiaires c'est vrai
que c'est peut-être un peu facile est ce
qu'on n'aurait pas intérêt à changer
effectivement le contrôle l'organisation
le contrôle la transparence sur cette
agence je crois que monsieur a raison et
les problèmes qu'il a qui l'a souligné
découle de l'extension considérable des
champs d'action de l'afd au cours des
dernières années il ya quelques années
l'afd ne s'occupait pas des questions de
gouvernance ne s'occupait pas des
questions de sécurité ne s'occupait pas
des questions militaires c'étaient les
ministères qui s'en occuper directement
alors effectivement je crois que ceci
pourrait être corrigée sans doute par
l'action des ambassades et des services
de coopération sur place les services de
coopération qui sont faits pour
dialoguer avec les gouvernements
bénéficiaires bien entendu il faut que
tout ça soit discuté il ya un dialogue
avec les sociétés civiles et c'est le
rôle de nos missions de coopération dans
les différents pays sous l'égide de 2,2
l'an de l'ambassadeur bien entendu et
puis peut-être qu'il faut aussi
améliorer le fonctionnement de l'agencé
elle-même comme vous le suggérez
actuellement elle est dirigée par un
conseil d'administration dans ce conseil
d'admistration il ya la tutelle c'est à
dire les trois ministères affaires
étrangères finances qui joue un rôle
capital et puis l'outre-mer et puis il y
a des députés des sénateurs au nombre de
4 5 personnalités qualifiées
et puis deux représentants du personnel
donc c'est assez équilibré et ça permet
au parlement d'être informés sur ce qui
se passe à l'intérieur de la fdt
probablement le parlement va s'inquiéter
de de ce qu'ont dit les danseurs
dallaire que sont les journalistes qui
ont lancé cette cette affaire et vont
vouloir en savoir un peu plus c'est leur
droit le plus absolu puisque la loi de
finances sur la loi organique sur les
lois de finances les autorise à
interroger dans ces cas-là une agence
d'état une agence publique pour savoir
ce qui s'est exactement passé et
peut-être que dans l'avenir en effet il
faudra réformer certaines des procédures
l'agencé est avant tout un organisme
financier est effectivement comment un
organisme financier petit le dialogué
avec la société civile peut-il prendre
en compte les questions de droits de
l'homme peut-il prendre en compte les
manquements des militaires ou des
régimes autoritaires
si évidemment c'est plutôt le rôle d'un
organisme politique de faire ça et c'est
l'organisme politique les ministères qui
ont la tutelle qu'ils doivent de les
instructions à l'afd vous l'avez dit
organismes financiers au delà de la
question des armes qu'on a évoqué il ya
évidemment la question prenons son nom
de la corruption sur sur le terrain
sous couvert d'ailleurs de secret
bancaire l'agent se refuse à donner le
nom de des collectivités des emprunteurs
des entreprises avec lesquelles elle
travaille on devrait selon vous ce que
l'on me lever ce secret bancaire
ep les états dans lequel la rd
intervient quand vous regardez dans le
classement des pays le plus corrompu du
monde en général et en partie de
l'archipel et ont donc attention quand
on arrive in intervient dans des états
où il n'ya pas de la transparence où la
corruption est endémique où on sait très
bien que l'argent public pas seulement
la zone délais de développement même
l'argent public du trésor public a
détourné alors quand on sait ces
réalités la r d doit pas de sa
responsabilité pour s'assurer que ce
qu'elle fait ne doit pas aboutir ou est
de tourner même si la ld donne l'argent
et après cet argent est donné à d'autres
personnes ou des entreprises ont des
influences ont des réseaux et ces deux
quartiers pas de la captation de ces
ressources de développement est
nécessaire de passer par ces autorités
qui sont des corrompus parfois ou qui
n'ont pas des tic dans la gestion de la
chose publique est bien la conséquence
c'est d'ailleurs à ce moment qu'un
départ est de ce problème donc il faut
prendre le problème dans sa dimension et
mettre les choses en perspective et que
chacun peint sa responsabilité qu'en
terme et dans sa durée faire de secret
bancaire ne résout pas les problèmes on
est l'un des responsables étant donné
puisque les acteurs de ces clientèles
s'est passé je ne peux pas dire que dire
que seulement à cause de ça pour régler
ces problèmes il faut être transparent
de bout en bout qui soit au niveau de la
r d ou au niveau de sécurité certaines
de ces lacunes exigence doit être
réciproque ceux qui donnent et ceux qui
le soir le monde est fait pour que leur
maison cette transparente cette
coopération notamment avec les pays du
sahel ça va être rendue encore plus
difficile avec ces tensions entre la
france et le mali aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui en effet une tension compte
tenu des déclarations qu'elle fait le
premier ministre du mali à l'onu samedi
dernier il a dit la france ou à laisser
tomber en plein vol ce qui n'est pas
tout à fait exact puisque la france dans
les six mois qui viennent va se retirer
trois bases qu'elle a dans le nord-mali
mais elle reste ailleurs
deuxièmement le g5 sahel auxquelles la
france participe comme sixième membres
continuent également d'agir dans les
cinq pays qui constituent cette zone n'y
a pas que le mali dans le théâtre est
beaucoup plus vaste et puis enfin il ya
la minus ma la force de l'onu dont
d'ailleurs le premier ministre malien a
demandé à l'onu samedi dernier que ça
son mandat sera renforcée de façon à ce
que cette ford venu puisse agir
véritablement de façon offensive contre
les terroristes ce qui n'est pas le cas
aujourd'hui alors tout ça est sur la
table effectivement plus les éventuels
participants tiers les etats unis qui
fournissent beaucoup de renseignements à
l'ensemble des troupes que père sur le
terrain les armes et des cinq pays qui
en fait ont vocation à prendre le relais
des militaires étrangers et à faire en
effet en sorte que les élèves et les
ministres qui sont ils et qui veulent
troubler l'ordre public puisse être
chassés de leur pays et puis peut-être
d'autres pays on entend dire un peu
partout que en effet
un organisme privé russe est en
négociations avec le gouvernement du
mali c'est bien possible d'ailleurs le
ministre de la défense et le premier
ministre du mali ont été formés à moscou
il ya eu déjà des coopérations donc à ce
moment là il faudra voir en effet si ça
se produit si ça se confirme comment ces
interventions se coordonnant avec les
autres parce que ça peut être dangereux
d'intervenir en ordre dispersé sans
aucune concertation en tout cas sociétés
privées effectivement saga l'avantagé
que cela n'avait rien à voir avec le
gouvernement russe en tout cas c'était
le message qu'il a fait passer il ya
deux jours merci claude blanchemaison
merci également à vous avez lé crime
koundougou me